[Music]
it's been a little over a week since
Oscar winner Michael Douglas got ahead
of his own sexual harassment scandal
well today his accuser is speaking out
he was the king of the world and that he
could humiliate me without any
repercussions journalist Susan Brody
worked for Michael Douglas in the late
80s at the height of the actors Fame she
told The Today Show she was constantly
subjected to sexual harassment the most
traumatic incident she claims was during
a script meeting when he allegedly
performed a sex act in front of her one
of my friends said you better not tell
people about him people were frightened
for me Michael Douglas did not comment
today but he D merely denied the claims
before they were initially published
quote this is a complete lie fabrication
no truth to it whatsoever I don't have
skeletons in my closet and Douglas has
the full support of his wife Catherine
zeta-jones who told us it was important
to quash the story he did his statement
he did it I think it's very clear the
way that he stands
I cannot elaborate on something that you
know that it's so very personal to him
what I can't say that it touches all of
us the oscar-winning actress has been
focused on her latest project which
premieres tomorrow on lifetime cocaine
godmother the Griselda Blanco's story
calm down every cop down in this city is
looking to cut off my head I wanted to
play this role for ever it's based on
the real-life story of the woman who was
a pioneer in the Miami cocaine trade
call you stuff in the kitchen live there
were a few times a few days when she
gave us that look that look of the
cooking God another one I would say grow
I couldn't wait to get to work every
morning and play in this world reminded
me why I wanted to be this in this crazy
business in the
place
you